israeli airstrikes have continued on
gaza throughout the day they've hit
palestinian islamic jihad positions
inside the gaza strip
the israeli military says it is
targeting watchtowers rocket launch
sites and weapons factories
some gardens though claim that civilian
houses have also been hit
i was surprised as they asked us to
evacuate houses near ibrahim shamilac's
home he is gaza municipality staff an
ordinary employee who provides for young
children
in response
more missiles have been fired from gaza
into israel
[Music]
air raid sirens have sounded in towns
near the gaza border including tel aviv
and israelis living there have been told
to stay close to bomb shelters
we do not want
any escalation and once you know we will
but we will we we are not in a position
that we can allow our citizens
to be in bomb shelters so once this
threat will be eliminated the operation
will be over
a five-year-old girl was killed in one
of the first airstrikes
israel says it is doing everything
possible to avoid civilian casualties
but there is evidence of women and
children among the dead and injured
israeli security forces arrested
suspected palestinian-islamic jihad
fighters in the west bank
they are hoping that the violence won't
spread out of gaza
jerusalem remains calm for now
the militant group that controls the
gaza strip has so far stayed on the
sidelines
if that changes and they get involved
this will escalate very quickly
egyptian mediators are due to arrive in
gaza
but israel's military operation does not
appear to be over yet
aleister bunkel sky news